at the age of 16 yet a master plan for
becoming one of the best know
journalists in all of Britain he's been
in the midst of media scandals he's
interviewed some of the most famous
celebrities and most powerful
politicians in the world and he's judged
the talents of hundreds of common folks
arrogance ambitious and shameless well
who is this media man well of course
it's none other than Piers Morgan Piers
Morgan was born in Sussex that's in
England in 1965 to an Irish dentist who
unfortunately died when Morgan was only
2 years old a birth Morgan was named
Piers Stefan O'Meara but Morgan's mother
remarried after his father's death and
Morgan he adopted the surname cue Morgan
Morgan and his stepfather
they were pretty close and Morgan having
never really known his birth farmer
calls him dad his parents they were
middle-class English they ran a pub and
they supported Maggie Thatcher when
Morgan was 13 years old the family could
no longer afford to send him to private
school so he had to leave behind the
classmates that he knew at his new
school well he was picked on and in true
schoolboy fashion the name cue well that
was changed to puke they are hilarious
our mate Morgan as you probably know he
dropped piu from his name later on I
moved that some have attributed to a
desire to separate from his middle-class
roots but that Morgan himself just said
was because P Morgan was too long for a
byline as a child Morgan he showed an
early affinity for the media as early as
age 7 he would sit at the table
devouring the daily newspapers reading
the headlines and discussing the day's
events with his parents now by the time
he was a teenager he was already writing
news articles even actually sold a piece
to the mid Sussex times and then to
cricket magazine at the age of only 14
he said of this it gave me the real
taste of the excitement of a byline it's
probably no surprise to you then that a
couple of years later when it was time
for a career to happen Morgan had set
his mind on the fact that he would
become the most famous media
in all of Britain he developed this
masked plan and opted not to take an
offer from Warwick University to study
history the reason for this was simply
because this would have kept his master
plan on hold for a few years while he
completed his education so instead he
went directly to Harlow College and
dived into the formal study of
journalism as soon as he could
[Music]
organs first formal journalism gig was
at the South London News and then he
joined the Sun to write the gossip
column which was entitled Azhar as the
Guardian put it Morgan spent his years
at the Sun grinning in namely while
posing next to a succession of
personalities well he wasn't disagree
with the Guardians characterization of
his initial years in the media as he
himself told the BBC he made a point of
putting himself in the middle of stories
posing for pictures with celebrities and
generally getting his name and face out
there for all of Britain to see well
this tactic it totally worked by 1994 at
the age of only 29
Morgan secured his place in British
media history when Rupert Murdoch named
him as editor of the news of the world
Piers Morgan he was the youngest editor
ever of the news of the world and the
youngest editor of a paper in Britain in
five decades the news of the world had
the largest circulation of any paper in
the country at the time and the
editorship gave Morgan a platform in
which he put his hard-charging oft
controversial journalistic methods on
display for a huge population of readers
he even else reached the previously
untouchable barricade of the royal
family by the summer of 1994 Princess
Diana and Prince Charles's marriage heir
was on its way to its official end and
organ and the news of the world they
weren't going to miss out on the
opportunity to publish on potentially
juicy Ronald scandals Morgan his quote
wins that James Hewitt an officer in the
British military wanted to spill the
beans about his affair with Princess
Diana with no fear of potential
repercussion or for the long-held level
of dignity with which the Royals had
been treated Morgan reached out to
Hewitt and arranged interview him for a
story
he and his associate they actually even
bugged the room where they did
interview so they could have absolute
proof of everything that was set then
later that year in the fall a book about
Prince Charles in his private life it
was set to be published while the news
of the world they didn't have any
excerpts the Sunday Times totally did
Morgan well he wasn't ready to give a
scoop to another paper and nor is he
willing to take no as an answer when he
was denied access to information from
The Sunday Times instead he directed
Rebecca Brooke Stewart helped him out on
the hotel interview to disguise herself
sneak into the Sunday Times officers
grab a copy and get it back to the news
of the world as quickly as possible well
this a little bit of espionage it
totally worked in the news of the world
they were able to publish the story
about Diana and Charles long before any
other paper except for Sunday Times
so if Piers Morgan wanted to be a really
famous journalist I mean why did he
settle for running gossipy relationship
stories well the answer was because to
him everything was news there is a type
of snobbish pompous journalist who
thinks that the only news that has any
validity is war famine pestilence or
politics I don't come from that school
this egalitarian attitude is allowed
Morgan to quickly prove his mettle and
his willingness to do whatever it took
to be successful in breaking stories but
he only lasted her the news of the world
for a bit over a year though Morgan said
he left the publication of his own
accord
the timing of his exit coincided with
the publication of a photo of Princess
Diana's sister-in-law leaving an
addiction treatment clinic the
publication of which even Rupert Murdoch
said went too far now in 1995 shortly
after this photo ran Morgan he moved on
to head up the mirror and other paper
owned by Rupert Murdoch here his tenure
hit lasted much longer than it did in
the news of the world the number of
controversial stories though it was much
larger and as a result his profile that
continued to rise even outside of
Britain Byrd's true form it only took a
year before Morgan found himself
embroiled in his first major controversy
at the mirror the day before England was
set to play Germany in the Euro 96
football championships the mirror
ran a headline and the photo on its
front page that many did not find very
amusing above a doctored image of two
players wearing World War two helmets
was the headliner Achtung surrender for
you Fritz Z Euro 96 Championship is over
next to it was a letter written by
Morgan himself in the style
Neville Chamberlain reportedly Morgan
also plans a publicity stunt that
involved driving a tank to the German
Embassy in the ensuing uproar about the
headline well that later stunt it was
subsequently canceled suddenly though
Morgan he found himself in this position
that is hard-charging personality it
didn't seem suited for yet to apologize
there were fears the kind of attitude
promoted by the headline may incite acts
of violence during the games though
Morgan he was apologizing he was still
right where he wanted to be and of
course that would be the center of
attention
in 2008 the attention turns from an
editorial decision he had made to a more
personal financial scandal a competing
newspaper published a story alleging
that Morgan had bought 20,000 pounds
worth of stock in a computer company and
that he had made the purchase just
before the mirror ran a piece naming the
stock as a good buy an inquiry began and
it was decided that while Morgan had
reached an ethical code of conduct he
could keep his job other mirror
employees well they weren't so lucky
economists who wrote on stock bonds they
lost their jaws it was another four
years before Morgan was cleared of any
wrongdoing however it actually came out
later that it bought additional stock
under his wife's name another 70,000
pounds worth by the time that that later
revelation came about Morgan was already
on the skids at the mirror as editor he
had been leading the charge against the
Iraq war in the British press allowed
Leigh criticizing then Prime Minister
Tony Blair for his support of the war
among the stories published on the war
and de Morgan's leadership was a piece
that included a photo of British
soldiers abusing Iraqi prisoners as
recently as a 2016 BBC interview Morgan
he defended the photos saying they were
real and that the British government had
a vested interest in getting rid of me
their biggest thorn in the side about
the war however the mirror it didn't
defend them strongly in the wake of the
allegations that they were actually fake
the British people instead they actually
got a paper with a large headline that
stated sorry
we were hoaxed and then the man who had
okayed the publication of the photos
well he was subsequently out of a job
when Morgan's firing was announced staff
members of the paper they were in tears
after nearly a decade Piers Morgan's
reign at the Daily Mirror it was over
[Music]
true to form though he absolutely did
not slink away into the night instead he
became a regular feature on people's TV
screens though he had already been
appearing on TV before leaving the
newspaper business
Morgan stepped up his involvement with
broadcast media after its firing one of
the first offers Morgan received for a
regular TV gig was via a text message
from Simon Cowell and then in 2006
America welcomes Morgan into their homes
she served as a judge on America's Got
Talent
he also judge Britain's Got Talent and
even appears on the then just a mogul
Donald Trump's reality show The
Celebrity Apprentice Morgan actually won
his season of The Celebrity Apprentice
and in the process became a close
friends with now president Donald Trump
Orkin said all along that he believed
Trump would be President and has been
outspoken about his dislike for the
protests that erupted after Trump's
election interestingly Morgan's
diatribes on the subjects have even led
some celebrities to decline interviews
with him but Morgan knew what opening
his mouth could lead to he's no stranger
to the ins and outs of the American
political and media institutions he
served as the host of a prime-time show
on CNN for several years after all so
when Larry King announced his retirement
in 2010 Morgan was named as the
replacement for the longtime
iconic American host the show it started
strong with Morgan able to book some of
the biggest names in media and politics
for interviews Oprah
Rudy Jia Lani Ricky Gervais Condoleezza
Rice and even two of the Colossians
sisters and well he made just as many
headlines for the interviews he didn't
do as well Madonna was deemed too old to
appear on his show and bands from ever
being a guest but unfortunately for
Morgan the initial hype it wore off
quickly Morgan had a different style
from King and he was a British person
taking over an American news and
interview show ultimately he lasted only
three years in the hosts chair as poor
ratings doomed to failure
he's attributed the show's failure to a
clash of cultures citing such factors as
his own outspoken opposition to guns as
one such example of cultural differences
that just couldn't be bridged the CNN
show though it wasn't Morgan's only
project during that time period
he was also hosting life stories for a
TV whose subjects were as diverse
Sharon Osbourne and the prime minister
and now today he's the permanent co-host
for good morning Britain where he keeps
himself in the spotlight mostly recently
sparring with a gender-fluid guests over
the validity of gender fluidity in this
interview and his pretty classic blunt
style Morgan asked the 21 year old guest
if you can identify as whoever the hell
you like can I literally look at myself
and say I'm an elephant today amidst his
rise to television stardom Morgan had to
contend with accusations dating back to
his newspaper days a 2005 the news of
the world which remember Morgan headed
up for a year published a story about
Prince Harry injuring himself the only
way that they could have gotten the
details for that story claimed royal
officials was if they had hacked
personal voicemails this set of a series
of event that rocked the British media
political and celebrity world arrests
were made investigations were done
lawsuits were filed and it took six
years before some actual action was
taken to address the phone hacking
scandal remember Zork II issued
apologies for the phone hacking in print
in the form of a full-page ad in the
last issue of the news of the world's
Rebecca Brooks the same Rebecca who
Morgan had used to break into the Sunday
Times office resigned as CEO of News
International after a resignation though
more bad news was headed away because
she was arrested but then she was
released on bail the FBI then opens
their own investigation into the news of
the world and the allegations that they
were hacking the phones of 9/11 victims
indeed this scandal was so wide-ranging
that even London's Police Department was
investigated for corruption
needless to say well the scandal it's
totally enveloped England and the world
it was paying attention though Morgan
had been out of the newspaper world for
some time he was not immune to being
questioned about the scandal in fact he
had to answer questions regarding to the
voicemails of one of England's most
famous personas Sir Paul McCartney
McCartney's ex-wife ever Mills had
alleged that her voicemails had been
listened to after she and the Carney had
had a fight in 2001 a reporter who
called her just seemed to know too much
and Mills maintained that she hadn't
shared the voicemails with anyone else
and that she had actually deleted them
all the only way the reporter could have
known so much was if he had hacked or
listen to the voicemails or had talked
to someone who had
Morgan admitted that he had heard a
message from McCartney to Mills and as a
result he was called to testify in the
2011 inquiry into foam hacking Morgan
wouldn't reveal how had come to hear the
message and he also maintains that he
never authorized the hacking of
voicemails at the news of the worlds or
The Daily Mirror the head of the phone
hacking inquiry lured Leverson called
Morgan's testimony that he didn't know
about the phone hacking to be utterly
unpersuasive and well despite his
denials of direct involvement in the
hacking Morgan he was interviewed by the
police about the hacking in both 2013
and 2015
[Music]
phone hacking incendiary headlines
taping interviews about the Royals you
might think there would be enough for
any one person to face in the course of
a media career but Piers Morgan he has
been embroiled in personal controversy
with other celebrities as well one much
publicized drama as temperature inaction
Morgan Turk as the editor of The Daily
Mirror he published photos of top-tier
host jeremy clarkson with a woman who
was not his wife barson understandably
was perturbed by these photos being put
out there for all of the world to see so
what did Parkson do well he decided to
hurl a glass of water in Morgan's face
that might not seem out of place in your
average bar but on board the last flight
of the Concorde the alteration well it
stood out and the fact that it was
between two highly visible members of
the British media well even better a
fuse between these two men well that
officially started and this feud it
wasn't minor thing it literally came to
blows in 2004 when Clarkson punched
Morgan in the head at the national press
Awards Clarkson broke a finger
Morgan gained a scar and these celebrity
gossip writers well they gains a new
story though the feud lingered for a few
years the two men were able to bond over
drinks in 2015
and while the feud ended at the time
Clarkson was going through a divorce and
confided about his troubles to Morgan
who was able to empathize I sense that
Jeremy's just pretty much like every
other 50-something in life angst-ridden
from damaged relationships grieving
loved ones irritated by work-related
issues and battling inner demons
[Music]
by the time he entered his 50s
Morgan was acquainted with many of the
same trials and tribulations that
Clarkson had dealt with his own marriage
fell apart by the mid-2000s and he and
his first wife Miriam shallow
officially divorced in 2008 after 27
years of marriage the marriage produced
three sons and Morgan makes a point of
staying in close contact with his
children in fact amidst all of the
demands on his time
Morgan has made a point of speaking to
his children every single day after his
divorce Morgan he began dating Celia
Walden a fellow journalist the couple
they married in 2010 later they had a
daughter
they both are British they now primarily
reside in New York walden often shares
details of the married life in her
columns and Morgan even joins in some of
the time the two even teamed up to write
a column about a trip to Paris in which
Morgan steps back from his desire to be
known by everyone Paris has always been
one of my favorite cities because the
French neither Know Who I am
nor can this means I can behave in a
wildly reckless manner and to maintain a
reasonable confidence that the shameful
images will never appear on the cover of
the National Enquirer though he claims
he doesn't want his own personal shame
shared in the National Enquirer Morgan
has made a career out of sharing the
intimate details of other people's lives
has never been shy about sharing his
political opinions or any opinions he's
made a name for himself he's made a few
enemies along the way and shows
absolutely no sign of stepping out of
the spotlight anytime soon from
middle-class Sussex to the TV sets of
people around the world Piers Morgan has
lived out the plan he wrote at the age
of 17 and he still got plenty of career
left to go what will the world seem next
from Piers Morgan well whatever it is
when it happens well will surely see it
in the news snaps Piers Morgan his life
welp so far if you didn't like this
video please do hit that thumbs up
button below do not forget to subscribe
for brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday check out some of our other
videos from the past over there on the
right and as always
thank you for watching